I want to talk about tar but I also want
to talk about your Sisterhood and what
does it mean I have my hand on her
bottom where else
yeah where
my tiny butt
what does this relationship mean to you
because it's I mean in Hollywood you're
in a very insulated tight Circle you
know I don't think that's true I don't
know I I do I think that there's been
this long-held
um maybe because there's there's not
been
um a vast availability of roles for
women traditionally obviously that has
changed more female directors as Sarah
Paulie was saying more female
showrunners more female writers and
um and so things have got more diverse
but there's a sense that the media has
made us into competitors and we were
just talking about that couldn't be
further from the truth you know like
it's it just doesn't happen that way
so I don't know no she just said it she
just said it
your turn
I want to ask you I want to take away I
want to ask you about this role though
because it seems like you flecked so
many muscles and it was so I mean
studying for it and all the things that
you went through to prepare for this
role what was it like preparing for this
role I look I was absolutely terrified
when when I when I
uh music you can't get away from the
music you know but but when I first read
the script I just knew that there in
order to get to first base to even play
the scenes there was a kind of a base
level of work you know when you have
when you're doing an action movie you
know you have to get fit so that when
you don't injure yourself yeah and so in
order for the audience to believe
um because Todd wanted to film it in a
fly in a wall kind of way that that this
woman was a maestro there were certain
things that I had to do before I even
could step on set so that was obviously
piano and conducting and even though
it's not a film about conducting you
know you wanted people to forget that
and move into the much more existential
kind of Haunting nature of the film
Jamie you're having so much fun here
tonight what how how much fun are you
having hanging out back here because I
wish people could see how much you're
soaking up the moments back here with
all these here's what I've learned if
you sit out there you don't see anybody
sit back here everybody walks by you
every single person that has been out on
that stage has walked by me I got up I
got to talk to them I I haven't seen
Michelle and Stephanie I wouldn't have
seen them out there but I saw them
backstage so that's my secret don't tell
anybody
everybody's going to be sitting back
here everybody next year will be sitting
back here well because it's for me that
was why I did that I'm having a good
time you know why because this is a
privilege yeah it is to have a fun
creative life to be able to be at a
thing I mean there's a lot going on in
the world right now there's a lot of
horrible things going on in the world
and there's a lot of things that we need
to focus on in the world and yet we're
in the movies and this is the season of
celebrating movies art artists and so to
say you're not having a good time to
take this too seriously would be insane
yeah and so I'm just thrilled that um
this one said to go to Palm Springs